asking out your crush is best done with
a simple three-step process step number
one is to get their attention you can do
this by either going up to them in real
life or by starting a conversation using
the internet once you have their
attention you can then move on to step
number two which is to say something
along the lines of hey I like you let's
go on a date at blank place at blank
time and finally step number three you
look them in the eye if applicable don't
say anything and you simply wait for an
answer and it's always going to be just
one of the following three things a they
say yes in which case congratulations B
they give you any excuse as to why they
can't go C which is a flat out no and if
they reject you embrace the pain and use
it to transform yourself pain is good
pain lights a fire within you so you
start taking action pain is what
ultimately makes you sexy